tenemos una recta numérica con el 0 en
el centro y en la recta numérica tenemos
marcados estos 3 números aunque ya está
la izquierda tenemos el número a luego
muy cerca del 0 pero todavía a la
izquierda del 0 tenemos marcado al
número b y finalmente a la derecha del 0
tenemos el número c y luego por acá
tenemos unas cuatro desigualdades y lo
que quiero es que ahorita le pongas
pausa al vídeo y te pongas a pensar
cuáles de estas desigualdades son
verdaderas
cuáles son falsas o tal vez para qué
desigualdades no tenemos suficiente
información como para saber si son
verdaderas o falsas bueno voy a suponer
que ya lo intentaste encontrar cuáles de
estas desigualdades son verdaderas
cuáles son falsas o para cuáles no
tenemos suficiente información y
entonces vamos a ver cada una de estas
desigualdades que hoy vamos a empezar
con esta de aquí
- ve es menor que menos pues lo que sí
sabemos es que ve es menor que se hace y
ve está a la izquierda de c
en la recta numérica y eso directamente
nos dice que ve es menor que se crea y
es así de sencillo b es menor que se
ahora lo que realmente nos interesa es
saber si menos b es menor que menos
aunque entonces esté menos b vamos a ver
en dónde está en la recta numérica
tenemos aquí menos b y eso lo que
significa es que estamos buscando el
opuesto de b
como ve ésta una marca a la izquierda
del 0 entonces menos b tiene que estar
una marca a la derecha del 0
así es que menos b está por aquí
ahora queremos ver dónde está - en la
recta numérica menos ahora menos c es el
opuesto de c y se está 12 345 marcas a
la derecha del 0 entonces menos se tiene
que estar 5 marcas a la izquierda del 0
entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 marcas a la
izquierda del 0 por aquí está menos c y
ahora si podemos comparar los menús b es
menor que menos se menos b está por aquí
menos está por aquí y entonces no menos
que no es menor que menos ok porque
menos b está a la derecha de menos en la
recta numérica entonces el más grande es
menos b así es que esto está mal
- b es más grande más grande que menos c
y si te parece muy confuso también
observar algo acerca de estos números b
es un número negativo entonces menos b
es un número positivo y por otro lado c
es un número positivo entonces menos c
es un número negativo y los números
positivos siempre son más grandes que
los números negativos y bueno también lo
podemos ver directamente en la recta
numérica menos b es más grande que menos
c entonces esta desigualdad es falsa y
ahora vamos con la siguiente desigualdad
menos b es más grande que 0 pues ya
sabemos en donde se encuentra menos b en
la recta numérica lo tenemos por aquí y
está una marca a la derecha del 0 quién
sabe cuál sea la distancia que
representa cada marca pero el chiste es
que menos b está a la derecha del 0
entonces menos veces si es más grande
que 0 así es que esta desigualdad es
verdadera
ar es más grande que ve pues observemos
lo en la recta numérica a está por aquí
y ve está por aquí así es que a esta a
la izquierda debe entonces podríamos
decir que a es más negativo que b aunque
es más chico que b crea y así es que
esta desigualdad es falsa para que un
número sea más grande que otro número
tiene que estar a la derecha de ese
número pero a está a la izquierda debe
entonces a no puede ser más grande que b
y finalmente vamos con la última
desigualdad será menos a más grande que
se pues por aquí tenemos a que está a la
izquierda del cero se está a la derecha
de a entonces sabemos inmediatamente que
se es más grande que a sin embargo que
podemos decir acerca de menos a bueno
pues vamos a tener que dibujar la en la
recta numérica menos
vamos a dibujarla en verde como ésta 1 2
3 4 5 6 marcas hacia la izquierda del 0
entonces menos a tiene que estar seis
marcas hacia la derecha del 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 por aquí está menos a y si nos ponemos
a observar esto de aquí menos a está a
la derecha de c entonces menos así es
más grande que se nos si es que esta
desigualdad es verdadera y bueno aquí
puedes sentirte un poquito confundido
puedes decir pero a tiene un signo menos
entonces a debería de ser negativa y por
lo tanto menor que un número positivo
como sé pero no es así porque hay es un
número negativo y entonces menos a es un
número positivo aunque tenga el signo
menos es un número positivo y está
marcas a la derecha del 0 mientras que
se está únicamente 5 marcas a la derecha
del 0 entonces menos a si es más grande
que 0